and welcome to
our webinar and expert conversation
on cyber security in a post covered
world
new challenges and opportunities and
we're with
rohit tama senior manager of microsoft
a bit more about rohit in a moment i'd
like to start by
telling you how to use the controls for
webex
you'll have a q a button with the
question mark
that will allow you to ask us questions
for rohit
and we will collect those
for the q a at the end of the webinar
session um where rohit will take them
live
you have a chat button where you can
communicate with
us during the session remember to use
all panelists
so that we all see it and hit send
and i'd like to start
with a poll today
and
hold on a second
first poll is going to be two questions
and the first question is what role do
you have
and the second one is how are you
feeling today
i'll give you about a minute or so to
answer that
what's your current role and
just on a scale of thumbs up or thumbs
down or
somewhere in the middle how are you
feeling today
on day 270 of the walk down
and we have a number of students here
today
and again i'll give you about another
20 seconds or so to enter your answer
and do remember to hit submit
okay and you can see rohit is here to
take a look let me
while we're looking at the poll result
here
introduce rahi and he is a senior
manager
at microsoft he currently leads a cyber
defense team
that detects in response to real-time
attacks
his established assurance programs and
cloud security requirements and
compliance
and he is the co-author of the book's
practical mobile forensics
and learning android forensics and we're
very glad to have him here today welcome
rohit thank you stuart and
i'm glad to be here as well
and um i'd like to start
with a question
just in general how have the
changes in operations that the pandemic
has driven how's that changed the opera
of the cyber security environment
we're all working from home
using different devices and a number of
other
important changes in our lives but how
does that affect cyber security
yeah i think that's a great question to
start with uh stewart
and let's break it down into two parts
right so let's
first talk about what are the
operational changes and then we will
talk about
how those changes have impacted the
cyber security
uh if we go six months back in time and
think about the
situation where lockdowns were announced
globally
uh at that point of time the priority
or the top priority for a lot of
organizations was
how do we ensure business continuity or
in other words how do we ensure that
business runs smoothly
so from an i.t perspective this
naturally meant supporting the remote
work
and having a proper channel established
for the
remote workforce to connect back to
their offices or workforce online
and continue to do their jobs
so in this transition those companies
that have
already been investing uh heavily in
supporting remote work
uh rather found it easier to make the
transition
uh but the ones who have not invested
enough uh
in in supporting the remote work they
had to make
or introduce a lot of changes overnight
uh
for example you know there are companies
uh
which started allowing users personal
desktops
or personal laptops to be connected back
to the corporate networks
uh there have been instances where you
know those services which were residing
inside the corpnet or within an
on-premise boundary
have been exposed over public internet
so that the employees can access them
and perform their
administrative actions uh similarly
there are
a lot of companies that started adopting
or
you know having vpn related setups
overnight without proper testing and
without proper
understanding of what is the right
architecture for them
similarly uh there have also been uh you
know a lot of companies that started
migrating to cloud in this journey
because everyone came to understand that
if the application is running in the
cloud then
folks could access it from anywhere from
any location
so there is an over migration to the
cloud as well so all of these are
you know some of the operational changes
that have been triggered because
of the covet situation uh and the
important point here to understand is
all of these have been done
in a very short span of time where there
is not
enough uh afterthought for security
or for security testing uh related
activities
by the way bro on that point i heard an
executive and i haven't been able to
track down the quote
but i did hear an executive say early on
if they had told us we had to transfer
everybody to work at home we would have
told them it took 10 million dollars
in six months and when it happened it
took three days
yeah that's exactly uh what i was
talking about
yeah great point there uh so now
uh coming to the you know impact of
these operational changes on
uh cyber security uh right let's let's
talk about
how they have affected i think what we
have
talked about till now we can call that
as a scramble phase where
enterprises were forced to make these
changes in order to
support the remote work and all the
operational changes i have just talked
about
you know they are going to have both
short term as well as long term impact
on the cyber security in short term i
think there is a lot of
increased attack surface that has come
up
uh that has resulted from you know
things like
unmanaged machines now connecting to the
corporate network
or you know exposing of assets to the
public
internet and also deployment of new
untested technologies like vpn and other
stuff
and for security teams in short term
this is a huge challenge as you can
understand because
they will have to now rapidly start
modifying their
existing processes and also technologies
to adopt to this changing risk
and on a long term basis uh given that
remote work is here to stay and also
given that we are now talking about
options like permanent work from home
and so on uh this is going to have a
tremendous impact in the way
cyber security is going to shape up in
the coming days
for example in order to support the
remote work
there will be a lot of infrastructure
based changes that will happen
uh in the uh enterprise setup over the
next few months or
over the span of next few uh one to two
years
as well uh so this will result in
realignment of the existing security
goals that the organizations have
and this will also result in adoption of
new security models like for instance
zero trust is something that a lot of
companies have been actively looking at
right
now and in the
backdrop of uh you know people working
from home
uh there also will be a need for
increased
security monitoring that has to happen
right so companies will start thinking
about what are the technologies that can
help them
in increasing the security monitoring
uh purview as such in the next few
months or years to come
stuart i think you're on mute
sorry thank you very much now that we've
talked about the changes in the
environment
um what are some of the specific
threats that are arising cyber security
now
yes so if you're talking about the
specific uh cyber security threat types
uh i think the first thing where we have
seen a clear trend in the increase of
number of attacks is the rdp-based
attacks
as soon as the remote work challenge
came into picture
and when companies started thinking
about what is the solution that can
overnight help them enable people to
connect to their machines
remote desktop connection is the first
thing that you know people found as an
easy fix
and if we look at the stats in the month
of you know
march and april there have been millions
of rdp servers that have spun up
uh which have been exposed uh
over internet right so naturally these
led to
remote desktop-based brute force attacks
where
you know attacker would be trying to
brute force log into these
machines that support rdp connections
and in a lot of cases we have also seen
that
these servers that have enabled rtp uh
connections
are not even running uh latest operating
systems
in fact there are reports that state
around 20 to 25 percent of these
have been running old and outdated
operating systems
which have reported bugs are publicly
available
and once you know once an attacker is
able to break or
guess a particular password for an rdp
endpoint
and once he's into that machine from
there we have seen
attackers installing ransomware and
moving laterally to other machines in
the network to compromise them and so on
so this has also resulted in increase in
the number of ransomware attacks that we
have seen
in the past few months and
other than rdp based attacks
we have also seen a significant increase
in the social engineering and phishing
based attacks
uh of course phishing is not something
new to the cyber security world
we have been dealing with it from almost
more than a decade
now uh but in the wake of kovid uh we
have seen
several covet based scams uh you know
trying to impersonate health
organizations across the world
uh and one of the common theme that we
have seen in
all of these phishing based emails is
the fact that
they start to target the weakest you
know link in the whole chain which is
the human emotion
uh for example we have seen covid based
uh
scams which send emails
stating that click here to see the
report of uh
covet cases in your company as such
right this is very enticing for an
employee
to go and click that link and once you
click that link
you know all sorts of malicious actions
can happen
they could steal the tokens or they
could drop a malware onto your system
and so on and apart from this another
area where which has also been
a target of attackers is the vpn based
attacks
as i mentioned in my uh initial
discussion that
several vpn based softwares have been
uh used overnight by the enterprises
without
proper testing or understanding of those
softwares so in several cases there are
you know unpatched vpn servers that were
spun up in in some cases there were
default passwords that were left
by the vpn elements uh so all of these
have
resulted also in increased targeting of
the vpn related
attacks as well
just a lot more exposure to a lot of
different um
attack points you know yeah
so um what strategies are companies
adopting to counter those threats and
protect those
endpoints
uh so the strategies might vary from uh
you know one company to another based on
what is their
current level of maturity in terms of
the
security uh processes but
in general right now there is a
increased focus
on new security models like zero trust
for instance
this is something that has come to
forefront in the
backdrop of uh the pandemic situation
that we are in
and this is a very hot topic right now
in the security industry about
adopting zero zero trust network so i'll
just take a minute to explain to the
audience about what it is and what is
the problem that it saws
uh in in traditional it network
security uh it is it is based on the
premise that
we have a perimeter and inside the
perimeter we have
all the assets that are being protected
and
if you are outside of this perimeter or
outside of the network
then it is extremely difficult for you
to access any of the resources that are
inside
but once you're inside the network then
you have a free-handed everything that
is present
inside the network now the
bad thing with this sort of an approach
is that once an attacker is able to
break in
uh he will have you know
access to entire resources at his
disposal and then he's going to go after
the crown jewels in your environment
uh the ones that hold the most critical
and sensitive data
so the starting point can be just a
small machine that is sitting inside a
network
but he can move laterally from one
machine to another exploring the network
and finally he would eventually land up
uh at the most important or the
sensitive ones
so zero trust network tries to address
this problem
by proposing a model where
nobody is trusted by default and
any access to any resource is granted
only after strict verification of both
the user who is trying to connect
and at the same time the device which is
trying to make the connection
and you would not be having access to
all the resources
but you will be having access on a need
to know basis which means there is a
very tight access controlled mechanism
that is implemented
which will restrict the access and
as you can understand right in the
current situation of remote work
uh everybody is talking about how do we
support remote work in a more secure way
and that's where the zero trust comes
into picture where it not only solves
the problem of remote work but also
proposes to do it in a more secure way
yeah so that's about uh zero trust uh
the
some of the other strategies that uh
that have that the companies are looking
at right now
is we talked about increased adoption of
cloud
in the beginning uh right where uh cloud
solves them some of the problems with
respect to access and
you know once data is in cloud you can
access it from anywhere from any device
uh so i think moving to cloud
might be simply about lifting and
shifting the data and resources
overnight
but having a sound security strategy
in terms of cloud is going to need some
bit of time and some bit of experience
for example all those enterprises that
are now moving to cloud
have to now answer uh questions like how
do they measure the security of the
resources that are running in the cloud
and how do they keep monitoring these
resources on a day-to-day basis
and what does it mean from it you know
security compliance point of view
and do they have enough tools to measure
the security
posture of these resources and if yes do
they have the
right security personnel and the teams
who understand the technology and who
can take right action
in case of a compromise or in case of
any uh attack on those resources uh so
cloud security is something uh that the
companies
uh you know will be looking at in a very
big uh
manner and apart from this i think uh
you know there will be a strategy to
figure out how to enhance the security
monitoring at every level
uh because earlier we had a process
where
everyone comes to office and we have all
of the monitoring related stuff
you know firewalls and all that stuff in
within the office and we keep monitoring
them but now
everyone is dispersed apps are moving to
cloud and in some cases they are moving
to multiple cloud providers
so uh there has to be a more unified way
of
tracking and monitoring these workloads
that are running at different places
uh and uh some of the
you know ml and ai based solutions that
are available in the cloud
that can scale up to the number of
events that are coming from these
uh devices and coming from these
workloads is also
something that companies will be uh very
much interested in in the coming days
it's an interesting discussion because
it's like the immune system of
an organism where it's not
just the skin that protects the organism
it's the each cell
in its own immune responses and defenses
um
that sounds kind of like a working
definition of zero trust
um so how would a company
go about implementing zero trust
uh i'm sorry did i did i freeze for a
second
yeah yeah but but i got the question i
think you were asking about
how do we implement zero trust is that
right yeah
yeah that's right yeah so zero trust
is not uh you know a single product or a
tool that
uh companies can adopt overnight it's
it's basically a security model that is
based on
uh on the foundation of certain
principles
uh for example you know multi-factor
authentication
is one of the very strong principles
that is part of zero trust
so what it proposes for example is that
if there is a resource and if somebody
is trying to access
let's say a user is trying to access
that resource before granting access to
that resource he needs to be
authenticated through multi-factor
authentication which means it's not
sufficient
if he's just logged in with his
corporate username and password
he should also be authenticated using a
different form of authentication whether
it is
authenticator app or whether it is a
phone based authentication
so this is a principle and now there
will be tools that will
support this particular principle and
you know organizations need to figure
out the context
in which they are talking about the
authentication and wherever applicable
they need to start implementing the mfa
and similarly network segmentation is
one of the
core fundamental principles in in zero
trust
and what that proposes is that if you
have a network
uh you know let's say we let's talk
about the corporate network
this needs to be segmented into smaller
chunks of network
or segments as we can call them and each
segment needs to be isolated from the
other segment
so that even if one of the segments is
compromised because of
an adversary attack the other isolated
segments are not affected because of
that
so once again this would need
implementation
in terms of understanding what is the
existing architecture
and how do we segregate uh into
different segments and how do we
implement it
so that is something that companies have
to again figure out on a
case-to-case basis apart from this
you know there is also the the
idea of restricted access or
access only on a need to know basis
which means that
no one would be having access to
everything by default
it will only be on a need to know basis
and it will only be for a certain time
let's say
you would want to perform an
administrative action
by connecting to a very sensitive server
now you will not be having access to
that server
forever but you will be having access
let's say
only for a specific time period let's
say only for a couple of hours or maybe
for eight hours
on a on a specific case to case
requirement so these are some of the
core principles and
as i mentioned it's going to be a
journey for the
companies in adopting this
because this is a transition to an
entirely new way of
you know enforcing the security and new
way of
running the infrastructure within the
corp um
so yeah so basically
uh it it it takes a company to
understand what is their current
architecture
where are they in the germany of you
know zero trust
and then try to fill those missing
pieces in uh if they have not
uh included them yet yeah i'm i'm
curious by the way just on a side note
it's one thing if the company has an
internal infrastructure
it's another thing when they've moved
to the cloud in all or in part
and now part of the infrastructure
is controlled directly by a third party
so
how does uh how do the third party
controls
of the cloud provider and the company's
internal controls
interact for zero trust
yeah i think that's a wonderful
questions to it uh so
i think if we are talking about the
journey to cloud right
we would notice that you know the cloud
providers who are there in the market
they do provide a lot of security based
tools and lot of security based options
uh
for the users or for the organizations
to track uh
the security posture uh but ones who are
moving into the cloud
the ones who are adopting the cloud need
to understand what those options are
and they need to come back and apply
what does it mean for their companies
and this could mean different things to
different companies
for example if if you are in the domain
of finance
or health sector then the controls might
need to be
more stringent but if you are in let's
say an e-commerce
sector there might be some other
controls that might come into play
uh and of course there is the angle of
privacy uh
where uh you know now we have a lot of
uh
consequences about where the data is
stored who has access to it
who is accessing it in the cloud and all
of that so
i think the biggest challenge is if
someone is moving to the cloud for the
first time
then it's going to take some time to
understand
what what tools are available for them
to leverage
and then apply it to their environment
uh before moving ahead
good great answer um
the how does this all
impact on the demand for cyber security
professionals
and especially ethical hackers who are
going to be testing the defenses
yeah so i think we have been uh you know
seeing multiple reports about the
shortage of cyber security professionals
and
we have been reading about it from
multiple sources
but let's talk about it uh in a more
logical way right
i think as long as we see more users
coming online
and as long as we see more work moving
online and more processes getting
digitized
it is inevitable that
cyber security the need for cyber
security professionals will also
evolve at the same pace
and some of the things that we have
talked about as part of the
strategies that the companies are
adopting right for example let's take
zero trust networks
and if the company is trying to
implement zero trust networks
and if they're trying to implement uh
device based identity
and multi-factor authentication they
would definitely
look for experienced professionals from
identity and security space
similarly for enhanced security
monitoring
they would look for people who can uh
who are well versed with using the
monitoring tools
and who can take them to the next level
right so
the demand is definitely going to
continue
uh as long as this uh you know
this journey to cloud and uh this
journey to
uh digitization across the world
continues the demand is going to
continue
uh but i think one point to note here is
that along with the demand
there will also be a change in the
expectations of the roles and
responsibilities for these
particular jobs or for these openings
for example if i think about the demand
for
application security based jobs five
years back
the qualifications were mostly around uh
you know someone who has good experience
in dealing with vulnerabilities
someone who has penetration testing
experience and so on
but today if we see the same role has
evolved
into uh into a more mature level
where companies are now expecting not
just the absence based knowledge
but also exposure to you know developer
pipeline for instance
because that would help them to
implement the idea of devsecops
or you know the developer based
devsecops model in their companies so
similarly even
in terms of uh tier one roles in sock
earlier uh they
used to look for people who had just the
monitoring experience
but now companies are looking for people
who have not just the monitoring
experience
but also someone who is comfortable in
scripting and writing
python-based scripts or partial-based
commands and who can help them in
automate
the day-to-day operational work as well
so
you know just to conclude you know the
demand would continue to grow in the
coming days
but at the same time there might be you
know different set of expectations that
the companies may have
for some of these roles
do you have some guidance or tips that
you would give
to somebody who's um either a fresher
who's
who's entering the field or maybe
somebody who's experienced in some other
technology aspect or operational
discipline but would like to look at
entering cyber security as a career
shift or change
yeah i can share you know a few pointers
uh from my experience and
you know i would request the folks in
the audience to uh pick and choose the
ones that might work for them
uh i think uh the primary
step would be to have increased
awareness about
the multiple domains and the multiple
variations of job
jobs that are present under cyber
security field
for example you know we have
security monitoring as a space
application security as a domain
we have security engineering we have
auditing compliance
security uh penetration testing
uh so there is a huge variation under
the bracket of cyber security so
the first step i would recommend is to
take some time to understand
the breadth of this particular field uh
and once that is done
uh i think the second step will be to
build on your existing strength
or the existing talent for instance if
you are
coming from a development background
then
naturally the application security or
source code reviews
kind of roles might be more interesting
to you and might be
ones that will help you to excel uh and
similarly if you have
uh you know inclination towards catching
bad guys
then roles like security monitoring
could be
of interest to you and let's say you're
someone who is interested in problem
solving
and designing high-level architecture
then security architects could be
uh the right choice for you so i think
uh
you know it's important to understand
what is your existing skill
and also understand what variations are
present in cyber security and to connect
the dots between these two
and in fact in my experience some of the
best people i have worked with
in cyber security are the ones who have
come from different domains
uh purely out of their interest in the
cyber security space
and like i mentioned i've seen folks who
have come from a pure dev
or programming background and they have
excelled in in
areas like source code reviews and
penetration testing and so on
because that will help you to develop
sound foundational
uh knowledge and then on top of it if
you start understanding
security then you then you will have a
complete end-to-end picture
uh in a better way
just to to follow up on that
um i'm curious how you've seen
people who have an operational
background who have looked at the
security problem from
this is something you know people are
attacking me this is something that i
need to
to understand how to defend against um
when they decide to become
more conversant in cyber security
principles and move into that as a
career
uh does that operational background give
them an identity
yeah so if if you're specifically asking
about
someone who has you know operational
background and let's say
a database administrator or a system
administrator
and who has seen you know some of the
attacks that involve databases of
systems
then i think that's a very good segue to
think of cyber security because like i
said
you know at entry level you don't need
to be
an expert in any of the domains that are
present in cyber security
but you need to have sound knowledge
about
a system that the hackers would normally
perform
and he would try to identify the gaps or
the security holes that are present
and like i said this could be in the
applications or this could be in network
or this could be at any level but it's
basically
an act of you know breaking the given
application by simulating some of the
payloads and
attacks that hackers would normally use
uh you are on mute stuart
i thought i would i thought i was
unmuting myself but i think i muted
myself
okay thank you for that explanation um
so uh
risha asks with 13 years of experience
in
qa how suitable
is it to make a move into cyber security
yeah so i think it depends on you know
uh
what what kind of qa experience uh he
had in
for these 13 years and what kind of
tools he is used to
uh you know if if it involves
you know certain level of security a
certain level of testing
or you know functional testing using
selenium scripts and other kind of stuff
then you know there could be a very
minor overlap with security testing
uh but yeah so i think it
it depends mostly on what kind of uh
qa experience he has and which domains
he has in those 13 years
okay um we have
a couple of questions on data security
one from a youtube uh viewer uh youtube
live viewer
ashwarya um another one from
a webex uh attendee i mean
and the two questions are how can we how
can we
secure our important files from hackers
and how do we handle accidental insider
data breaches
yeah so i think coming to files right
so if we are talking about the files
that are
inside the corporate environment and we
are not talking about the personal files
then we have certain controls like
you know rights based access management
where you know for example in if you're
talking about
ms word or you know related to any of
the documents that we handle
as part of ms office then you could also
manage the rights
in terms of who can have access to that
particular document
for example i could set a permission
saying anyone within my company can
view this particular file or i can have
a permission very granular saying
these are the only set of people who can
open this file even if they have and if
the file lands in the hands of other
people
who are not you know in the in the
allowed list
then they would not be able to open the
file uh and the same rights are also
replicated in some of the cloud
providers like office 365 so if you have
a document that you want to host online
and then you want to share it with only
few people
then you can do that using the rights
management
within within those kind of tools
and the other question had to do with uh
handling accidental insider data
breaches
i guess both prevention and um
and amelioration after they happen
yeah so there are certain data loss
prevention solutions that can help
uh with this both with intensive and
also an intentional
lake of data so once we tag
the documents and files with right level
of access
then there are certain data loss
prevention tools
that can be deployed to track uh
the movement of these files in and out
of the
machines and in and out of the network
and based on certain anomalies
we would be able to flag in case let's
say you know a very highly sensitive
document is being sent to personal
emails or
to other recipients who are not intended
to receive it
um we have a couple of questions on xero
trust one of which
is uh just in general
dinesh asks wouldn't
zero trust in other models in the wake
of this
current situation or post covenant
situation
wouldn't they require uh new and
expanded it investments
and we know that organization
organizations are per shy
so would that slow down adoption of
these new
techniques yeah i think that's a great
question and
uh both the points are valued right on
one side
there is a need to support the remote
workforce and they need to do it in a
right way
secure way so there will be interest
in technologies or in security models
like zero trust for sure but on the
other hand
you are very right in pointing out that
uh in the
wake of current situation where there is
a general budget reduction for the iit
as a whole
the cyber security budgets are also
going to take a hit
so that's when i think the
prioritization of the existing security
goals
will come into picture uh for example
before kovid
a lot of organizations have already had
a list of you know certain priorities
for the next one year
but now all of those have to be
reprioritized
uh and budgets and budgets and including
security personnel
will be uh invested in in supporting
uh new frameworks like zero trust rather
than chasing something
uh which may not be a top priority right
now for
organizations uh so that also leads us
to a situation where
over a period of next one to two years
as we invest more
in the in the immediate problem of
securing remote work
there will be a technical debt or there
will be a security debt that is going to
build
over a period of time uh because we are
not acting on the
pile of other gaps that we are already
aware of
that makes sense um the the idea of
technical debt in security is
a little bit frightening
yeah the um one
whenever he just asked um
does zero trust mean that we're gonna
have to reduce the use of single cyanide
no single sinon does not have
uh any such implication on zero trust
uh single cylon is a process where you
sign into ones you authenticate once and
that identity verification will be
carried along to the
other portals or other resources that
you sign into
so that will continue to be the same but
where zero trust might come into play is
you may not be uh having uh you know
permanent taxes once you are signed in
in other words the amount of time for
which you have access to a particular
resource
might be limited and you might be asked
to re-authenticate
based on certain policies certain
conditional policies
that might come into picture
we have a number of questions that
regard
um certifications in general
and do you
find that
certifications are
helpful to the
learners in seeking employment after the
after their programs yeah so
i'll just share my personal opinion and
uh it's not necessary that
it that's everyone should hold the same
but i think certifications can
definitely uh
take you to one level uh in other words
they will help you to
have to move in the right direction and
they will give you a good structure and
outline
especially if you're new to the cyber
security right
it's they they would be very helpful to
you to navigate through
and stick to your specific outline and
be able to say yes i have covered these
and now i'll be able to work on these
but i think
it would be helpful only till that level
or you know
they could help you in the initial
screening if you are applying for
certain jobs but once you are you know
sitting in an interview then what really
matters is
you know what level of uh technical
expertise and understanding you have
about the fundamentals of that specific
domain which is what is going to land
you in that job
right so as long as certifications are
used with the
the right bent of mind that
you know they would give you a good
navigation
structure a good direction then totally
go for it
very good and um what are you know
i guess one of the the questions is
how does one choose
i think we've talked about this how does
one choose
between the different areas in cyber
security
i think if you go back over and and
reiterate what you said earlier about
playing to your strengths um that would
help
sure so i think like i said the first
point is to
uh be aware of what are the different
opportunities and different
work streams that are available in cyber
security and the second thing would be
to
assess what is your current strength uh
for example if you have come from dev
background
uh then programming is your current
strength and then you you need to
connect the dots between programming
and one of the work streams that is
present under cyber security
called let's say application security or
source code reviews that is present
similarly if you are coming from let's
say networking background
then you would have you know great
advantage
if you are part of you know network
security monitoring teams
uh and like i said if you're passionate
about problem solving and
looking at high level architecture then
a security architect role might be
the right choice for you so in in short
identify what is your existing skill and
try to connect the dots
with one of the work streams that is
present in cyber security
um i do have a question from a
uh audience member who
is pursuing a doctoral program and
she's very interested in what topics
and security challenges would be
good areas to focus on for
doctoral studies
so i think dockers and container
security
is uh something that's very niche right
now
uh and i think especially the
dockers and some of the
cloud providers like whether it is aws
or
azure right now there is a lot of
interest to see
what security controls can be
identified for those that are running in
these cloud environments
uh although we know generally about uh
what is docker security and what are
some of the vulnerabilities that are
applicable for dockers
right now there is no straightforward
way of you know scanning and finding out
what are those gaps uh within the cloud
provider environment
so that could be an interesting space to
look at
yeah um
the user cha asks can you elaborate on
application security and code review
and how to get started in that area
yeah so application security is a field
that deals entirely with reviewing
web applications or web services and
trying to find out
what are some of the vulnerabilities
that are introduced at the coding level
for example if you have heard about sql
injection or cross-site scripting
these are all vulnerabilities that are
identified as part of application
security analysis
and code review is a part of it it's
also called static
analysis where the reviewer will be
looking at the source code
that is present and he or she would be
trying to identify
what are some of the gaps that are
introduced at specific lines of code
and they would be articulating what is
the impact of those
uh vulnerabilities what what can an
attacker do
by exploiting those uh bugs that are
introduced in the code
and similarly there is also something
called dynamic analysis as part of
application security
where you will not be looking at the
code but you will be looking at the
application at runtime
and trying to figure out uh what those
bugs are
and that's more close towards the
penetration testing that we have talked
about
where you simulate something you enter
certain payloads and see
how the application is responding and in
that process you try to identify
uh what could be certain bugs so
if you're asking about how do i get
started with that uh
there is a good uh documentation that's
available
in site called ovasp owasp
and you can just google for os top 10
vulnerabilities that will just give you
a good introduction to
what kind of vulnerabilities we are
talking about uh and from there
you can go further i think
the last question that we'll take um
so what are some of the major factors
that you
need to consider this is from rashmi
what are some of the major factors
you need to consider in cloud security
as opposed to
uh security for on-premises
infrastructure yeah i think there are
multiple factors that need to be
considered for example if you are
talking about
on-premise there is a very tight control
around who has access to what because we
have active directory in on-premise
which defines who can sign in who can
access what kind of
resources etc but if you're moving to
cloud
then that visibility is lost very
quickly
and especially for dealing with
multi-cloud environment
then it becomes even more complicated to
find out who has access to what and all
of that
so access control is one big challenge
similarly the second thing is about
security monitoring right so
we have security tools deployed within
the corp environment
which will monitor inbound and outbound
traffic and try to find out
if there is something malicious but how
do we replicate the same
level of controls in cloud you deploy
the application in cloud
now how do i know what is happening
behind the scenes
and if there is an attacker who has
compromised it
uh how do i even get to know right so
that's another challenge
around how do we figure out
about the security monitoring piece in
cloud
and the third thing is uh even in terms
of
enforcing the controls right how do we
enforce those controls for example in in
cod incorporate
uh you know there are gpu policies where
you can push
certain uh policies onto the machines of
the user
you can restrict him from accessing
certain sites using
a proxy based uh servers
but how do we do the same equivalent
enforcement in cloud
so that enforcement angle is also
something that comes into play
and of course the lastly the compliance
perspective
you know in terms of where is the data
actually residing
uh is there enough backup for this data
who is accessing this data or everything
that revolves around data privacy
uh is also uh something that's very much
important to
consider as one of the factors
that's a very comprehensive answer i
appreciate that
um and at this point
i know that we have a lot more questions
that have come in but we don't have
time unfortunately to take them all so
i'm going to um
say thank you to rahid for being with us
and ask you if you have ways for people
to keep in touch with you
uh thank you stewart i would take i
would like to you know just
uh take a moment to thank simply learn
for inviting me
and i would like to thank arjun and
stuart from simply learn
for helping me and giving me the enough
support and also all the people who have
taken time to join in for this session
today thank you very much
okay and can people um besides linkedin
can people
contact you on twitter or other uh
venues or
what's the best way yeah i would prefer
to uh
use linkedin uh that's something that uh
that would be
uh more uh comfortable for me yeah okay
very good
um so thank you ricky and at this point
i would like to um
turn it over to uh siobhani
singh who is the chief admissions
counselor for post-graduate programs in
cyber security
and she has a brief message about
one of our new programs in cyber
security so
going to
give her the ability to share her screen
hello siobhani
hello shivani
let me um
do the following
hold on for a moment
oh shivani are you
we're having trouble with her audio
unfortunately
just a moment apologize for the
difficulties here
you
and
i'm going to go ahead and present
this material a postgraduate program in
cyber
security
in cooperation with mit
mit was founded in 1861 it's ranked
number one in technology
among universities in the last several
years
and has a very prestigious
record um its engineering programs are
among
the best in the world and we've formed a
partnership
with mit for postgraduate
program in cyber security
which covers a number of the skills that
rohit has described and
takes you through to a full
cyber security expert
certification it includes
content from mit faculty
it gives you the full post graduate
program
certification from both simply learn
and the mit schwartzman college of
computing
and a certified ethical hacker
certificate from the ec
council
so we recommend this program for
people who want to enter cyber security
and achieve a high level of
expertise and certification and
their certification supports
virtually all types of
roles within the cyber security area
and the price is
24 lakh in india
5500 in the rest of the world
and it's open to anybody with a
bachelor's degree
with 50 or higher marks people with a
non-programming background can apply
because you can't
you will be given programming training
and certification during this program
this uh postgraduate program and
you do not have to have prior work
experience
so with that i want to say thank you
again i apologize for the technical
difficulty there
we're not able to get
audio from shivani
we want to
invite you
to join us for our next webinar
one week from today we will be having a
webinar slightly different time
9 30 p.m india time which is 8 a.m on
the west coast 11 a.m on the east coast
in the united states
and that's glimpsing the future how
cloud computing will continue to change
the world
with quentin hardy of google cloud
and we'll be sending out information
to all of our attendees today on how to
register for that webinar you can
connect with us
simply learn on facebook twitter and
linkedin
and we want to thank you all for being
here today
um we have concluded the webinar
so again thank you and it's time to
exit webex
[Music]
you